another setback for the women of
Afghanistan
it's the start of a new University term
but only men are allowed to attend many
here at Kabul University are urging the
authorities to reconsider inshallah
I am hopeful that the elders and the
officials of the Islamic Emirates of
Afghanistan will allow our sisters to
continue their studies because it's
their Islamic right
now that we don't have female students
one part of our societies prospering
while the other ones left behind their
female students are allowed our society
will improve a hundred percent
the Taliban government banned women from
higher education three months ago after
accusing female students of ignoring a
strict dress code and a requirement to
be accompanied by a male relative to and
from campus there's been widespread
International condemnation of the ban
but no sign of a change in that decision
there's an element of all of this coming
from the taliban's insistence to try and
distinguish themselves from the previous
regime in Afghanistan try and show to
their constituents to their supporters
and fighters in particular that they're
not like the previous government
since it returned to power in 2021 the
Taliban has also banned girls under 18
from going to school prohibited women
from working for Aid organizations and
banned women from Parks gyms and public
baths rights groups who support Afghan
women say it's had a devastating impact
on Afghan Society to think where these
women are now I mean if they're in
Afghanistan I just hope they're safe and
if they're outside they're just
scattered to the winds and it's just not
the way the world should be in this this
day and age it should never have been
the way the world should be and I don't
understand
I don't understand the thinking behind
it I just don't
after the Taliban took power in
Afghanistan it promised women
fundamental rights 18 months on it
systematically excluding them from
public life Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera